[Music]
mary joins us up next she is in fort
worth texas mary welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you so much for having me on i
appreciate it absolutely how can john
and i help
well i have a question and i hope it's a
simple answer uh so i have uh two boys
one is already in his second year in
college away from home and my second one
is going to be graduating in may
he has decided to attend community
college to
avoid debt
with that said
i totally support him with that with
that said his um
i'm recently remarried for about a year
um so my new husband feels that i sort
of baby him and he feels that once he
graduates in may that i should be
starting to charge him rent
i'm not totally in agreement with that
but i don't know if that's just the mom
in me saying that or does he have
um i guess a good a good side of it that
i'm not seeing
um i think we're conflating two separate
conversations here okay okay so one is
the skin in the game the kids going to
college the hey you're an adult now and
making adult decisions let's have adult
conversations that are going to be
different than we had when you're in
high school
the other is
your husband
your new husband saying hey
i think you
um have a are babying this young man
and so those it looks like they're the
same conversation they're not one of
these is a
um i want our household to look a little
bit different and i want these boys to
begin to grow up and then the other is a
business conversation you get the
difference there so
anytime somebody tells me that the their
their romantic partner gives them this
kind of feedback my first question is
always are they right
do you has your son let me put it this
way how long were you um were you
divorced previously did your husband
pass away yes okay no i was divorced for
about nine years okay can i ask you a
really hard question
sure did um one or both of those boys
help fill that gap that space
um as far as not having like a partner
during that time that's right
um
i i really would like to say no i like
to say that i treated them both of the
boys very equally
um my older one is a little bit more
like i want to go do my thing make my
decisions and i supported him to do that
um i did you know give him the
suggestion of as far as the school debt
but um at the end of the day they can
let him make his own decision so
sometimes what i've seen over the years
is when somebody when there's a home
with divorce let's say and i'm just
picking that out out of the blue because
you and i are talking um i'm using an
example because you know we're talking
there's some sort of parental guilt that
they
will try to um extricate from the
relationship by over helping with one of
the children okay or both of the
children i'm gonna give you what you
need sure you can do this sure i'll be
there for you sure i'm not gonna miss
any games i'm gonna i i'm gonna try to
backfill this hurt with all this other
stuff
and i'm wondering is that what your new
husband is calling out
um to be honest i'm not sure um
sometimes he'll make comments as far as
like the chores he does or as far as me
asking my son to um
contribute i'll be honest i um i my son
works um so i i do provide him um an
allowance until he graduates
um
but as far as him asking me for
expensive things he doesn't really ask
me for anything um
so i don't i don't know if i'm missing
something i don't know if it has to do
with the route he had as far as his
childhood or am i just really babying my
son well so i think i think there's two
different conversations so i think you s
you tell your husband hey you said that
i'm babying him and
this is going to be a boundary
conversation for your new marriage tell
me more what are you seeing that i'm not
seeing because over the last decade i've
been by myself on my own i've been doing
my best to try to love these two boys
and i love your feedback because you're
a grown man i'd love your feedback now
we're entering into a tell me more
conversation that's not gonna be no i'm
not yeshua or no i'm not right so that's
number one number two
um in fact before we before this column
came in george and i just happened to be
talking about this earlier today on off
air
i think there's several ways to approach
the
rent conversation the
should you pay into it my friend mike
his dad had a great thing that a
suggestion that i loved he just sat down
when mike graduated college and said hey
you get six months rent free
you you can cash it in over the course
of your adult life
and he was like all right cool and so he
lived the first month after he graduated
and his dad came in and goes five left
and he's like oh oh you mean like and
he's like yep i mean for so
here's here's the important thing it's
set in boundaries it's setting very very
clear here's my expectations you can
live rent free for one year and then
we're going to charge you 500 a month
you got to get a job or we're going to
charge you rent out of the gate i think
all however you all do that the
important thing is that you have very
clear boundaries with time deadlines on
them with responsibilities with if
you're going to live in this house you
still have to come home at midnight
whatever y'all want to do it's the
messiness and the all over the placeness
that just wrecks relationships george
what do you think yeah i just think
having those ground rules in place is
going to be key whether or not you
charge them rent or not i still want
ground rules and i want to know what the
exit strategy looks like is this 10
years or is it six months it can't be
extended high school exactly so i think
as long as he's working he's working a
job i think there's nothing wrong if you
want to charge him a little bit of rent
you know give him a taste of what adult
life is going to be because he's going
to have a payment like that to factor
into his budget and so maybe you say hey
what are your financial goals great
here's the agreement you're going to
live here but you're going to build the
emergency fund you're going to start
investing you're going to save up that
down payment whatever that looks like
let's have a goal for why we're doing
this and here's what else i love i would
love your new husband to be a part of
this because this is half his house too
and so i want him to be a part of
setting the ground rules for the home
that your son is going to choose to live
in after he graduates high school so
he's going to talk to both of you this
isn't going to be the side deal between
son and mom that you're going to try to
go pitch to
your new husband
everybody's going to be in the room so
that your new husband can say my
expectation is fine i'm going to give
you a year rent free here
you will do the yard you will help with
the light bill you whatever those are
going to be uh and again that's a
separate it's almost a business
transaction if you would of course it's
your son and all that but this is a
how would we approach this from a
business angle
the other conversation is hey this is a
broader picture you see of me and how i
interact with my loved ones
it's going to impact your marriage
that's a different conversation that i
really want y'all to have but thank you
so so much for that call yeah how does
that sit with you mary
um
it is a another way to look at it to be
honest um i really didn't think about
having a meeting with all all three of
us and really seeing i mean i like the
part that you shared where you know it's
part of being an adult so that is a good
way to definitely look at it thank you
for the feedback you got thank you so
much for loving your son man that's
fantastic good stuff that's on your new
marriage yeah this is a big one john
parents are dealing with this and
especially millennials there's a
sandwich generation who's dealing with
the kids are still at home but i'm also
trying to take care of my elderly
parents and when you add debt to all of
that it creates a mess and so the best
thing you can do is have that the
financial discipline in place and
it sounds like he went to community
college to avoid debt which i love now
if he was strapped with debt and he was
like mom i'm broke and i got to live
here it's a different situation well and
sometimes kids do the math and and
they're great at it right they'll sit
down he probably sat down with a
spreadsheet and said i can go to this
community college and get these classes
do this much it's going to cost me this
great
but they don't factor in
the cost of being alive right and being
alive is expensive the cost of being
alive sounds like a great book title
it's expensive right yeah and so the
cost of being alive right now is rent
and
insurance and cell phone and all these
other things
and so all of every family does it
differently a friend of ours their their
oldest daughters got married and was
like hey i'm gonna buy a new car it's
like good this is a good time for you to
call the insurance company right and by
the way what you do with that cell phone
now you're gonna be married some people
wait till then some people as they're
graduating high school sit down and say
all right here's what's gonna look like
the next five years you're gonna go to
college we're covering tuition you're
gonna pay but it's all about that hard
conversation and you've got to have it
otherwise it ends in messy you don't
love me you never and you're like i gave
you ever it's just stop all that yeah
have the hard conversation and the worst
thing you can do as a parent is you let
them go into adulthood because you were
you know trying to take care of them and
cover every single bill and they go wait
i got how much is insurance what is get
oh my goodness i had no idea how much
life costs and so the sooner our kids
can learn that the better and that's why
i'm excited about a personal finance
curriculum that's in high schools
because kids are going oh i learned this
stuff now before it's too late right or
before i got thrown into the deep end of
the pool right yeah